Is this Kurdistan's moment?
Are they going to finally achieve independence?
You know, if you ask any Kurd that, they're
going to say that they want independence,
but the problem really comes down to the Kurdish
leadership.
Masoud Barzani, the leader of Iraqi Kurdistan,
who's now serving the ninth year of his eight-year
presidency, oftentimes tries to rally Kurds
around the flag of Kurdish Nationalism, but
when push comes to shove, it seems he wants
money more than nationalism.
Remember back in 1996, he invited Saddam Hussein's
forces into the Kurdish capital simply because
he didn't want another Kurdish rival to take
power.
Now, when it comes to the PKK, this group
in Turkey that's waging an insurgency, or
this group in Syria which has established
as an autonomous region, they're no longer
officially talking about separatism.
They're talking about federalism.
They're actually talking about what they call
democratic autonomy or confederalism, where
they want a group of Kurdish regions which
overlay other countries.
So what’s your opinion of Kurdish independence?
Let us know in the comments, and also let
us know what other topics you want us to cover
here at AEI in sixty seconds.